[Musique]
tout en moi on va faire des courses et
hypermarchés iago c'est ce qu'il faut
pas un anniversaire de ma soeur c'est un
beau cadeau en finançant pour acheter
une petite bouteille d'eau gros des
caisses qui raconte à notre gros cubes
tenez c'est ça qu'est ce qu'il raconte
une seconde et monsieur l'agent de ces
messieurs qui ont quelque chose à vous
dire youpi c'est l'anniversaire du
moment on va papa tu pour attendre que
d'autres sont servis
[Musique]
oui on va l'essayer poursuites
voyons un peu
au loin c'est écrit en japonais
attendez laissez moi faire
[Musique]
vous attendez attendez ça y est je crois
que j'ai compris
et tout ça pour faire des carottes
râpées
[Musique]
je
hahaha
[Musique]
tiens à cars 2 à poney ne bougeait plus
un petit sourit remercie vivement vous
pourriez me traduire les modes d'emploi
[Musique]
neuf ans c'est très jeune tien est son
gentil cwa poney s'il vous plaît tout le
monde en voiture
[Musique]
meaney mourinho maintenant on écoute
professeurs
[Musique]
moi oui
pour mieux vous comprendre
apprenez l'homme étrangères sayonara
hasta luego de bail en voir tous à tous
et merci
c